soit unie du reich and because my story
is so lahoud
lorsque j'avais 20 ans j'étais un jeune
étudiant j'avais pas beaucoup d'argent
j'ai eu beaucoup de difficulté dans mes
études j'ai redoublé neuf fois j'ai eu
mes diplômes avec beaucoup de
difficultés et pourquoi parce que
j'avais faim et j'avais honte de le dire
j'avais honte de le dire parce que la
fin c'est une souffrance difficile c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut pas dire
facilement parce que la honte de dire
qu'on a faim les gens peuvent pas
comprendre et ça a un impact sur les
études c'est un impact sur le travail
sur la vie de tous les jours lorsque moi
j'ai décidé en fait de me m'impliquer
contre le gaspillage alimentaire c'est
parce que je voulais attaquer et défaire
la fin il faut comprendre que chaque
supermarché jette tous les soirs plus de
50 kg de nourriture consommables dans
les poubelles
cela représente environ 1500 euros
1600 $ par semaine ça à peu près 16
mille euros et par an c'est plus de
150000 180000 euros
en face de cela on a une aberration
incroyable vous avez les gens pauvres et
on a de la nourriture consommables jeter
tous les soirs dans une poubelle
il faut réunir ces deux aberration on a
mis la puissance de frappe qu'il fallait
en france pour faire passer cette loi
parce que les supermarchés jeter tous
les soirs de la nourriture et récupérer
la tva les taxes dessus il récupérer les
taxes et qu'il vendait ou pas
les invendus alimentaire il était
gagnant dans cette affaire avec
différents lobbys comme les pesticides
et ses pesticides qui entraîne
la malbouffe la malnutrition l'obésité
le cancer les maladies cardiovasculaires
et de l'autre côté les perdants ce sont
les paysans les fermiers la classe
moyenne
cette fameuse classe moyenne qui
derrière ici même à des problèmes un
américain sur six ne mange pas à sa faim
ces 35 millions de tonnes de nourriture
consommables qui sont jetés dans les
poubelles à hollywood boulevard
une au niveau de bois y aura des seuils
robles donne in france and not coming
years to say you what you have to do and
coming years to do to say you we need
you we need américano et sur cette loi
nous avons besoin de l'aide des états
unis d'amérique pour faire passer la loi
pourquoi parce que 1,3 milliard de
nourriture sont jetés dans les poubelles
tout le temps
chaque année ça représente un tiers de
la production mondiale de la nourriture
une nourriture sur trois est jeté dans
une poubelle
lorsque dans le même temps vous avez 100
millions de malnutrition lorsque vous
avez plus de 40 millions d'américains
qui se sont opérés de malnutrition
lorsque vous avez plus de 1 milliard de
personnes qui ont faim la france a voté
la loi
le 3 février 2016 je voudrais remercier
le député français frédéric lefebvre in
the congressman changer petit à kingston
tokyo frédéric in france vous passez des
lots tant que tu dis cela aux more than
three free farzad association agressive
and soul food and more than ten milian
mills had av
distributique tout pour personne le camp
du design things we need you in order to
fight again we have to fight in order to
fight en défaite hanger tant que ce
match i'm sorry toi tout autant qu'une
frange bataille rap d'atouts en hausse
en maille message distinct que ça match